everyone doesn't think you know I could
become a world champion
um do you think that I know that I know
that I will the people who watch me
can't even [ __ ] believe that I'm
beating these people so they say it's
rigged and is there an element of like
some of the people be stepping the ring
with they're like all right fine I'll
take it like I'll shut the YouTuber up
100 they all thought they were going to
be that person you know even Tyron
Woodley really thought he was gonna beat
the [ __ ] out of me I hit [ __ ] hard
and I'm I'm a real problem what's up
with you and Dana White these Fighters
are basically enslave contracts you
could go in your next fight you could
fight somebody who's a professional
boxer but maybe doesn't draw as much
money as say you go and fight Andrew
Tate I've always uh leaned on going with
a tougher opponent always
haven't gotten in the ring with me are
they scared yes I I believe so people
say oh you have a chip on your shoulder
like I have two chips on my shoulder uh
one on each side I'm hungry I'm
Relentless and I will show the world
that I'm a world champion who's the
person that if you fight you're like I
will not I can't believe I'm in the ring
with this person and like let's [ __ ]
go all right guys bang bang I've Got
Jake here with me uh I thought a great
place to start would be you started off
your career on the internet you weren't
fighting you weren't doing anything
you're making content if you had stuck
with YouTube could you have been bigger
than Mr Beast
no no no why not he's uh obsessed with
it and has like such a deep passion for
it and so simply just because of that
you can't beat someone who loves it more
than you yeah were you obsessed with it
just he was a more obsessed or it was
something that you knew was a stepping
stone to some other career yeah for me
it was a stepping stone and I just did
it since I was a kid and I was like good
at it and it was making a lot of money
um and I worked really hard at it I
innovated changed the game like of
course but
um
I I saw a gap in the market when I first
started vlogging where like people
aren't doing this in a dope way they're
not telling story lines they're not
connecting all their Vlogs they don't
have a cast of characters
um so I I definitely was like Innovative
in that sense because I was good at it
but I knew this wasn't what I wanted to
do forever and
um there was a point where
I actively like stopped
doing YouTube Just because I I couldn't
stand it anymore yeah um when you
started doing the YouTube stuff did you
have friends that are like what the [ __ ]
are you doing
yeah yeah I I mean at first it was just
like so early on like my friends thought
it was like funny and we were all like
just go around the town making these
crazy pranks and crazy YouTube videos
and just like uh doing stupid [ __ ] all
the time and
everyone loved it when we would upload
the videos and we would get like 300
views which in high school that's like
damn near the whole High School
um and the teachers thought it was funny
that the teachers would like play it on
the TV screens and that's really where
it all started and we were just bored
like my brother and I got a camera and
there was nothing else to do in the
summer so we'd literally be sitting
there outside and we just started
pressing record and we'd watch the
videos back and think it was hilarious
and then we just really just started it
as a as a hobby one of the things I see
with a lot of people who end up being
successful creating content on any of
the platforms uh you pretty much know
like hey this video is going to be viral
this one's not it was how you guys
fought early on like it was almost like
this innate ability to understand this
is going to play or you have to learn
that over time yeah no I had to learn it
over time I think one of the videos that
we've made went viral and once we got
that taste of viral success we're like
okay a video has to be this good
um to you know get featured on the home
page of it was Vine at the time
um and so I set a standard and a bar and
then slowly we realized okay like
you you really have to create genius
concepts for people to to pay attention
here and to share it and for it to get
sent around to people and
um once we got a little bit of a taste
of that uh we just
tacked that you know that formula every
single day and um
over time like now I know what videos
will go viral or what won't but
um there there still is some like
Randomness to it though too like you
can't always you can't always predict it
to a t but Susan and the YouTube God's
Gonna bless you you know the CEO of
YouTube I feel like sometimes the
algorithm they just like you sometimes
they don't so it's a little bit of a
luck of the draw yeah man and
it's weird now it's just like super
strict and I I saw this coming like a
while ago where
all the algorithms were changing there
was so much more competition
um and now you have to really like hack
the algorithms in like the first 30
seconds of the video matters so much
it's all about watch time you know if
you swear in your videos it's gonna go
to less people and it's very like
PG
and it's a science yeah it's it and
that's the science that Mr Beast also
mastered and he curates his videos
because you know you have to okay you
have to watch to the end to see who's
gonna get the money who's gonna get the
prize but the whole entire time it's fun
because people are getting eliminated
and so his style of video you know you
start watching it it's big you know bold
cash it's it's curated for a younger
audience who's gonna sit there and watch
the the whole entire thing and that's
that's he's a numbers guy when I when I
first met him the biggest thing I was
surprised about is he just is like
mathematician with all that is there a
similarity between him studying like
game film essentially of other YouTubers
or even himself and what you're doing
now with boxing and kind of how
obsessive you are with trying to be the
best boxer in the world for sure yeah
and then that goes back to the passion
and the drive and the the desire to be
the best and I think in boxing I started
you know late so there's this uh I I
have an uphill battle and that's where
the obsession comes from and it's uh
it's something it's a sport that you can
never master and to me that is exciting
because you could always learn something
new
um you could always add to your game
um and everyone doesn't think you know I
could become a world champion
um do you think that I know that I know
that I will and to me it's just going to
be like a fun fun journey and a
crescendo to this crate already crazy
boxing story
um
but
definitely accredited it all to that
hard work and that people don't realize
how obsessed I am with it like I'm
really a student of the game I have
three coaches watching me of every
moment while I'm practicing and and they
correct you know if my toe position is
not in in the right spot the angles at
which I attack how I'm turning my
punches over what combinations and uh
just down to the finest details watching
back film uh every single time after
sparring which a lot of pro boxers don't
do a lot of pro boxers interestingly
enough don't even film their sparring
sessions
um and even fewer of them watch it back
with their coaches
going second by second you know
depicting and changing and talking about
what was going on in that film
um and then doing that on a consistent
basis and then even watching I watch
other Fighters with my coaches and we
um
just talk about everything that they're
doing what did your training regimen
look like on the boxing side right like
I think I I've talked to you enough now
where I think I understand uh you really
are obsessed with it but if you sat down
with someone and was like let me prove
that to you like walk through the daily
training regimen because I think that
speaks volumes to like the work you're
doing when the cameras aren't actually
on yeah yeah so
um you're literally laughing because you
know that it's [ __ ] insane that's
insane I'm like okay so and then let's
just take like a Monday in camp at this
like at the start of Camp
um
it would be you know wake up
um
right right away like have some oatmeal
um and then usually we would go to the
boxing gym box for
like an hour and a half
um to two hours and that's Shadow Boxing
hitting the mids hitting the the speed
bag
um maybe hitting the heavy bag
um you know
go going over talking about stuff and
doing certain drills with the coaches
um and then after that I would uh
typically
do a cool down stretch I have like a
stretch therapist for 30 minutes and
then I go into this red light bed that
we have with Like Oxygen
um to get rid of like my oxidative
stress and sit in the red light therapy
bed and then uh go home
um get another meal taken or sorry ice
bath at home ice bath Hot Tub at home uh
then get another meal take a nap wake
back up at night go back in for the
strength and conditioning workout
um which is could usually be like three
to five mile jog plus like a
weightlifting session so it'd be like
back and buys or if it's legs were
lifting for like an hour hour and a half
um and then abs
we do abs after that and then neck
workouts as well
um neck workouts are like a big part of
our regime just having a strong neck so
you can get hit in the face
um
and then another cool down stretch
after that oh hand-eye coordination too
so we would do like speed drills with
like catching tennis balls and stuff
like that
um and then another cool down back again
into the red light uh the red light bed
and then back home ice bath again
um
shower eat
do some business then go to sleep so
when you started let's say you were at a
zero world champion it's a 10 where do
you think you are right now in that kind
of Journey to being good enough to be a
world champion
that's a good question I would say I'm
probably at a seven or eight
um
probably more like a seven and a half
and
exponentially growing because once you
understand the game and you you know put
in those ten thousand hours which is
what I'm like approaching you can make
my new adjustments and you have the
muscles you have you know the cardio you
understand the ring you're comfortable
you fought in front of 20 000 people
that's that's half the battle it's half
mental so mentally I'm a world champion
fitting physically my it the boxing is
just catching up
um and it's not going to be that much
longer but I Spar against world
champions
um like former world champions as well
um Steve Cunningham he was like a
three-time world champion Chad Dawson uh
three-time world champion and what
happens when you guys are sparring
you're sparring against people who
obviously are very skilled who have had
a great success in boxing is it like oh
cool I can hang with them are you
knocking them out like what does that
look like are they knocking you out
what's happening no it's I'm hanging
with them and uh sometimes I win rounds
sometimes they will get around
um but they're not they're not in their
Prime right so they're like form they're
former world champions um
but I've gone up against the best of the
best like current people uh who who are
in the top ranks and I always hang with
them and people like can't believe that
you know you even see like when I
announced I was sparring with Chad
Dawson
all the comments were like haha like man
it's it must be so nice like Chad's
taking it easy on him like if you
actually sparred Chad Dawson uh he would
get knocked the [ __ ] out and read the
comments yeah yeah for sure I I read a
lot of stuff I think it's good to know
the opinion of
everything that's out there and I think
I let it fuel me and I think it's I
think it's funny because
basically what my boxing career has come
to is
um
if you can't convince confused right so
like they the the people who watch me
can't even [ __ ] believe that I'm
beating these people so they say it's
rigged right they say my fights are
rigged they can't believe it so the fact
that and I I understand where they're
coming from because this shouldn't be
possible no boxer in the history has
done this
um no one's taking on this tough of
opponents this early on in their career
they usually build up 25 fights then
fight someone tough for the first time
so I I take it almost as a compliment
where they seriously like can't believe
how good I am and so they make up lies
and are they rigged no no no no no
um I I would go to jail and it to me
it's they put like show times reputation
on the line too and Anderson Silva like
you really think
the goat of MMA is gonna uh take a
couple extra dollars to look like get
embarrassed in front of the world like
these are guys who have pride who
they're going in there because they want
to win and and is there an element of
like some of the people you step in the
ring with they're like all right fine
I'll take like I'll shut the YouTuber up
is that a little bit of what drives our
shirt to do it for sure
100 and they all think they all thought
they were going to be that person you
know even Tyron Woodley really thought
he was going to beat the [ __ ] out of me
um and then they just get matched they
get hit with this
this kid who is [ __ ] Relentless and
doesn't back down and can handle the
moment and I hit I hit [ __ ] hard you
know since my first sparring session
uh the coaches were like what the [ __ ]
you've never boxed before like how are
you punching like this
um and so you're getting there without
the headgear and the 10 ounce gloves
and I'm I'm a real problem like for
people and I think every single person I
get in there with is shocked I've seen
it with Anderson Silva too I really
think he was like all right like gigs up
I'm gonna be the guy to take this guy
out because he would have been Legend
status then right like there's some of
these guys who if they're the one to
stop you there is almost like uh okay a
catapult to the next level and like I
did it for the sport to something 100
like I I you know the MMA Community
definitely doesn't want me to keep on
winning
um and I don't I don't think most I
think the boxing Community is changing
like I think they're starting to
understand that I'm good for the sport
great for the sport and
you know bringing new eyeballs and
um really respecting the sport
so I think the boxing Community is like
starting to uh change their tune but the
MMA Community definitely doesn't want uh
to see me continue to knock out their
goats right like Tyler Woodley was one
of the best welterweights ever
Anderson Silva was the greatest MMA
fighter of all time so
um what's up with you and Dana White
you guys don't like each other I I mean
I I it's nothing like really personal I
guess
um I just don't like how he treats his
Fighters and he's done vindictive things
now to like try to [ __ ] up my fights and
uh
um like what
he
he was basically sending Seasons assist
letters to my team about the content
that I would had posted
um with him in it trying to get like
threatening to sue me
um unless I took the content down like
promoting the fight basically
um and then we think that he was the one
to send that video to the commission of
Anderson saying he got knocked out in
sparring so that like really like [ __ ]
up the pay-per-view and and the ticket
sales like you we saw all the pre-buy
numbers like tank the week of the fight
because everyone thought the fight was
off because Anderson put out or had an
interview like months ago months before
saying he got knocked out in sparring
um and that's a that's a risk so the
commission basically freaked out and
every there was rumors that got out and
everyone thought the fight was basically
going to be canceled
um would you fight Dana White like if it
came down to it and uh whether it was
pay-per-view or it was for like charity
or something and it was going to be the
one of the biggest fights of all time
from our audience standpoint would you
get in the ring with them for sure yeah
100 would you win easily easily he he
knows that like he he wouldn't fight me
like
it would be it would be a lose-lose
situation for him so you would knock
Dana White out easily easily he he was a
cardio kickboxing instructor that's
that's how he started
um
like a dude with the microphone like
yelling at people in the classes at like
a LA Fitness bro how long did it take
you to figure that out
um I know you went deep in the internet
for that yeah
come on you're literally you're a me
you're a meme Lord I got it but like
talk to me how did you figure that out
no so someone told me that they were
like yo like when I started feuding with
him someone texted me was like yo this
guy started as a [ __ ] cardio
kickboxing instructor like he wasn't
even the real person behind the UFC it
was all the Fertitta brothers that did
all the hard work and brought in the
capital about this guy just got lucky at
the right place the right time and then
I I found the picture though of him
actually being the cardio kickboxing
instructor and it's it's hilarious but
that one took me a little bit to dig up
do you agree that the UFC wouldn't be
what it is today without Dana or do you
think that he actually got lucky this
episode is brought to you by eight sleep
good sleep is a game changer and the
eight sleep pod is the best sleep
machine I sleep funded every single
night a great night of sleep allows you
to be healthier be more arrested and
have more energy throughout the day and
on the brand new eight sleep pod 3 you
can sleep as cold as 55 degrees
Fahrenheit or as hot as 110 degrees
Fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself in each sleep you
can go to eatsleep.com pump today to go
ahead and get 150 off your order
eightsleep.com pump not only do I sleep
on it every night it literally changed
my life and I begged the founders to let
me invest in the company eightsleep.com
go get yourself an eight sleep pod and
get a better night of sleep no I I don't
know I don't think he got lucky I think
he's a really smart guy I and I have
respect for what he did for the sport of
MMA people think I don't like the UFC I
love the UFC I grew up watching the UFC
I think it's a great organization they
put on awesome fights I love half of the
UFC fighters are my friends like
um but they need to pay their Fighters
more and that's really where the Riff
and the back and forth came from
because they only pay their Fighters 16
of the revenue whereas in the NFL and
NBA the fighters get fifty five zero
percent
um could the math work could they make
could they pay 50 make them out yes yes
yeah no the UFC is the most profitable
Sports organization in the world got it
and it's because they pay their Fighters
like [ __ ] and only the superstars get
paid decently like the superstars should
be getting paid more but the heavyweight
champion Francis manganu
gets got paid like eight I think 600 or
500 000 for his last fight right the
heavyweight champion of the world in
boxing
Tyson Fury got paid like 32 million
dollars for for his last fight um so the
fact that they don't have a long-term
Health Care in the most dangerous sport
in the world
um and these Fighters are risking their
lives
and some of them could barely afford
their gym bills like
to me that's where I want to see the
change and that's why we're working on
the United Fighters Association with
Anderson
um
because I I know how hard these Fighters
work and how much they're sacrificing
and it just sucks to see them getting
taken advantage of and
um and like I said they're the most
profitable Sports organization in the
world because they don't have to pay
their Fighters and these Fighters are
basically in slave contracts and the
crazy part about it is like
the UFC fighters they have to pay for
all their own [ __ ] you as a fighter you
pay for your own meals you pay for your
own coaches you pay for your own uh
sometimes travel depending
um
and so they're getting paid like [ __ ]
and you know the they have to pay for
all of those things
um whereas you know in the NFL they're
getting paid
a [ __ ] ton of money and all of their
coaches are paid for their gyms are paid
for their transportation is paid for
their meals are paid for
um so just this it's just this really
backwards thing and would you fight in
the UFC like if they gave you a contract
would you fight how if if it meant they
raised their fighter minimum pay uh to
fifty thousand dollars per fight
um and increase the the revenue that
they paid their fighters from 16 to at
least like 30 or 40 like it doesn't have
to be 50 but they could literally double
Fighters pay and still be the most
profitable profitable Sports
organization in the world
um so if it meant yeah changing uh and
helping the fighters I would I would
fight in the UFC for sure could you win
for sure for sure I mean obviously if I
went up against Like A Champion but
um
but if I had someone you know who was
evenly matched in in experience
um I I know I would win I just have I
just have a winners winners mindset and
I I would take the training very
seriously I have a wrestling background
um I know a lot of Jiu Jitsu just from
wrestling and rolling around on the Mets
so I would really just have to learn the
kicks because I have the boxing
um so I I could definitely get really
good at I've seen you post a couple of
times uh Joe Rogan being like basically
Jake can fight right yep uh how
important has his uh endorsement or his
kind of positive comments about your
actual abilities forget all like the
[ __ ] and the marketing all that but
like your actual boxing abilities how
important is it to win over people like
a Joe Rogan or others with big audiences
that understand the game of fighting uh
to help change the way that people look
at you in the sport no it's it's uh it
means a lot and and it's needed for sure
um and he has so much credibility I
think probably more credibility than
anyone you know if there's a top three
credibility and fighting list Joe
Rogan's damn at the top of it if not
number two or three
um and he has that that big audience but
he gets it you know he's seen more
fights than anyone he knows how hard it
is to knock someone down like Anderson
Silva how hard it is to knock out Tyrone
Woodley
um
so
he sees what I'm doing and he's right
like he's basically said if I wasn't a
YouTube kid and I was just a young
boxing Prospect beating all of these
people everyone would be like what the
[ __ ] this kid can punch like he can
knock people out this is going to be a
world champion but for some reason they
just say oh it's fake fights are rigged
this is [ __ ] and I even see people
say oh Jake is paying Joe Rogan to say
this and like to me like it it just gone
there was a slippery slope of like
disbelief and people just
discrediting everything that I have
worked for in this sport
um and and the slope
is is so much more slippery now and
there's really no coming back from that
I think people will just always some of
the people that I call them the Sheep
like the people just believe whatever
they're told or just get swayed by other
people's opinion
the Sheep will I think always be like oh
no it's fake oh like I don't know when
they're gonna
credit me yeah well I guess maybe the
question won't ever is there something
that you think that you could do where
they'd be like all right fine [ __ ] it I
was wrong like he is good is it
literally you have to become the world
champion and anything short of that is
like oh we told you he sucked and it was
a fad and and uh it was all rigged I
mean I think I'm fighting a professional
boxer you know and I've tried multiple
times and they've all backed out so
people just still say like oh fight
someone your age fight a professional
boxer and it's like what they don't
realize is Tommy Fury is a 10 times
easier fight than Anderson Silva why
he doesn't have the experience he's
never been in a tough fight he's only
fought people who are taxicab drivers
um
the the dude like isn't tough he's not
he's not good he's never been hit he's
never been tested not only that
he's only fought in one six round fight
all of his fights before that were four
rounds so like he's never even gone an
eight-round fight so it's like fight a
robot like this guy is manners and Silva
is a 10 times more real boxer with who's
been in there with the best strikers in
the world
um
but for some reason again the sheep look
at the title professional boxer and they
think
that that person will be better than
Anderson Silva so is there somebody in
the boxing world that you're scared of
or that you don't want to fight
I mean anyone in my weight class I don't
give a [ __ ] yeah like
I I will go in there and give everyone a
run for their money and that's that's
right now you know you you give me two
more years I'm getting exponentially
better each year I have the best coaches
I have the best trainer as I mean uh
regime I have the the best everything
around me so I'm exponentially getting
better and I'm I want it more than
than all of these Fighters because
they have been doing this their whole
life
um and that they're they're
I guess going through the motions and
just doing what they've always done but
I'm new I'm the new kid on the Block I
have a lot to prove I have people say oh
you have a chip on your shoulder like I
have two chips on my shoulder uh one on
each side I'm hungry I'm Relentless and
I will show the world that I'm a world
champion how much of this are you
interested in making money versus boxing
and I'll give you a perfect example uh
you could go in your next fight you
could fight somebody who's a
professional boxer who like the boxing
world would respect but maybe it doesn't
draw as much money as say you go and you
fight Andrew Tate yeah who people are
like look he's four-time kickboxing
champion like he's no slouch either
right but uh there's way more money
probably in fighting an Andrew Tate
because of pay-per-view ticket sales
like the hype that can be around it
almost more like a marketing event uh
and that's not to say that the fight
itself wouldn't be real but it would be
viewed very differently like he's
fighting against you tapers he's
fighting a professional boxer yeah how
do you make those decisions like how do
you decide should I do something for the
sport of boxing or should I do something
that's going to make me money I've
always uh leaned on doing something for
the sport of boxing and and earning
people's respect and going with a
tougher opponent always
um
they just haven't gotten in the ring
with me they've pulled out twice are
they scared yes I I believe so and even
now Tommy Fury is
creating all these smoking mirrors and
he's ducky and he wouldn't respond to my
DM I sent him a DM like yo you have the
offer in your inbox like let's make this
fight happen for the fans and he's he
just hasn't even opened it and it's like
are you dming him right now no yeah like
I'm sending an offer tomorrow we either
need to do this or move on
for good as the fans are fat are fed up
look at the comments in your tweets this
is a big fight and now it's on the edge
of being irrelevant your dad claims you
want this you say you want this and I
want this so sign up
and he didn't respond
and it's like all these smoking mirrors
I I I don't at this point I think he's
just
playing us to just get the brand
recognition who's the person that's on
like I call like goat Mountain for you
right who's the person that if you fight
you're like I will not I can't believe
I'm in the ring with this person and
like let's [ __ ] go
I think um Canelo and people
like were the two biggest names in the
sport and two biggest pay-per-view draws
in the sport so not only is it a massive
fight uh but because of
our Styles and how we match up styles
make fights right
so because of how we match up people
going into it we'll be like oh canelo's
gonna kill Jake canelo's gonna kill Jake
um but I know I can win and I'm gonna
give him a hell of a run for his money
um
and
that would be just like an iconic iconic
fight to make and and just for the
generations and I don't know I think it
would just shut the internet down
um and and I know I can win so you could
be canola yes
does he know that or you think he thinks
he could whoop your ass I think he
thinks he could whoop my ass and that
I'm just a YouTuber kid
have you tried to fight him yet like
have you guys tried to put a contract in
front of him
um we've talked to his lawyer and I
think he's getting to a place where he
sees like how serious I am like I think
at first everyone thought this was a
joke and that I was just my mouth was
bigger than my actions at first and now
my actions are matching up to what my
words are
um and so I think now people really have
to take that seriously and especially if
it's a year from now especially if it's
two years from now
um
I'm I'm sparring people that uh were in
both of their training camps for when
they did for this last fight Triple G
I'm sparring triple G's sparring
partners I'm sparring canelo's sparring
partners Ellis like all all of these
guys I forget the other dude's name uh
Sergey uh but I'm I'm respiring people
from both of their camps um and they
came out to my camps
um so when you look at a fight like that
right uh Canelo is this massive name uh
got immense respect within the boxing
world uh we've seen these like I'll call
them crossover events obviously McGregor
and Mayweather are probably the the
biggest one where I remember watching
them promote the fight and they're like
laughing at each other they're throwing
the money they're like playing this game
which on one hand you're like got it
that's part of what they're doing and
they're promoting it well and people are
gonna buy this Pay-per-view on the other
hand like that didn't look like a
[ __ ] joke when they were in the ring
with each other and they were really
punching each other yeah and so is it a
similar type of draw here where you're
very good at marketing you're very good
at using the internet and doing a lot of
this stuff Canelo has a respect to the
boxing world and so like you kind of
clash the stories together but there
actually would also be a really good
fight in the ring because of the Styles
and kind of where you guys are both
coming from exactly you know for sure
and I think all of it would just be an
entertainment spectacle and I don't
think anyone's gotten into canelo's head
and I think that would be like part of
it for me is I think I could get into
his head I think I would win the mental
battle
um
so you were the robot what say it again
you were the robot would get in his head
yes yes yes the the problem but yeah you
want the big one that follows yes yes
yes
yeah the giant robot that you have
followed you Jake
do you have other robots I have two
robots both of them are giant ones yes
all right
um one's a better bot it's the better
um I guess mascot and then one's my
mascot what about your brother so your
brother fought Mayweather uh and I think
a lot of people when they when I saw the
videos I'm like most people I'm like
there's no way these guys are gonna
[ __ ] fight right but like great
marketing awesome grabbing the attention
of the internet and they got in the ring
I was at the fight and I was like damn
it's the fourth round it's the fifth
round sixth round like Logan's still
coming out of the corner he's still
fighting and I think it kind of
surprised people a little bit and there
was questions right people were like oh
is it real is it not whatever but then
to see your brother do that now he's
gone on to the WWE and he's do doing
things where if you look at like a
highlight reel people are just like how
the [ __ ] is this guy able to do such
athletic moves and so early in his
wrestling career you both seem to be
kind of attacking related but different
Industries uh in this like fight related
game is that just because you guys were
athletic or like what is it that has
allowed both of you to be so successful
um yeah I think it goes back to we've
always loved Combat Sports and we were
both wrestlers but also we're
entertainers and that's why I think like
boxing you know fits me perfectly every
everything about it not just the fight
but I I'm an athlete at heart that's
what I started out doing and people
intend to forget that I was jogging
before school you know at five in the
morning staying after wrestling practice
to lift weights I won the hardest worker
on my wrestling team award my brother
was a yeah State uh State third place at
State as a wrestler his senior year
um All State football
um so boxing fits me perfectly and the
WWE fits Logan perfectly he he can
backflip he could do the splits
um he picks he's a quick learner
um he's acrobatic he would even when we
were kids he was really good on the
trampoline like he could do all the
tricks and so he that's why he feels
comfortable flying in the air we
literally had like a tree house as a kid
that we would jump off of onto the
trampoline and so he naturally the kid
was practicing for this his whole damn
life
um and for me I love the you know the
outfits the the dressing The Fight Night
the walk out
um so I think we both finally just found
our passions and Logan fits perfectly
within the WWE and I fit perfectly
within the sport of boxing let's talk
money
um how much money do you expect to make
on a yearly basis I think the public
number is 50 million I think it's pretty
accurate uh of what you made last year
um is that something where if you keep
going and doing what you're doing you
think you'll be making 50 million bucks
every year uh just fighting or like how
do you think about that yeah I mean
that's like if I fight like three times
a year which is like a really busy busy
schedule and
um it's proven to be harder now to get
people into the ring to sign up to fight
me
um but yeah if I if I can keep that pace
of fighting three times a year uh then
that that should be the number
um and and that's with like big fights
that's if there's no like Mega fight
um where you could earn 50 million at
first single Mega exactly exactly but
the number seems to be like 10 to 20
million dollars per fight depending on
how it performs okay uh what do you do
with the money like you and I have
talked in private you're not an idiot
it's not like you're taking the money
and going to the club and just throwing
it out you know and letting anyone grab
it what are you actually doing from an
investment standpoint are you making
those decisions do you have a team
that's doing that how do you like
operate with money once you've made it
yeah uh it's a good question definitely
doing a lot of Investments through my
fund I'm the biggest LP within my own
fund and we do we we invest into so many
different types of companies
um a lot of stuff around crypto but also
just consumer in general consumer
products
um
so put a lot of money there put a lot of
money into things like eth Bitcoin uh
BNB
um and
yeah just have always done that uh for
for years now
um was very early on but I bought
Bitcoin when I was like 16 years old
um why'd you buy it my friend told me to
buy it and I had like he's my he's my
genius friend like who's older
millionaire and he's like this is going
to be the future and I was like all
right sure how do I buy some other
coinbase like
um
so just have always like followed that
and then
um recently been
just putting a lot more money into uh
into Morgan Stanley like so more
long-term you know not as big of yields
and you know just like a slower growth
profile
um with like what like a private bank
team or something like plus managers
yeah wealth managers what is that
conversation like like I would love to
hear you talking to them about investing
are they telling you what to do or you
telling them no that's a cool plan but I
want to do this other thing like how
does that work no they they're mostly
telling me what to do for like non-risky
okay investment so
you go take the risk and then they'll
take care of those safe stuff exactly
and they and they tell me what their
game plan is and I'm like well maybe we
should tweak it a little bit but like
on that side I'm good at venture capital
I don't really know about the stock
market and all that stuff so that's why
I went to them to handle that and they
came like highly recommended there's
like a team of five of them
um and we just do calls like every
quarter or so and they're like all right
we'll put in more money here we'll put
it in there this is when the Market's
gonna we we think it's gonna go like
this and then boom like did you
interview that like you were like hey I
might go with this team or I might go
with this team or did you just take the
first one that somebody recommended no I
I
um got like three people three different
teams that were like highly recommended
and I talked to all of them and they
just like fit the best
um like personality wise yeah and just
like their capabilities and uh
I think like trustworthiness when you're
giving someone that much money you're
like yeah yeah you want to feel good
about it you do a lot of venture
investing and one of the things that
Founders specifically uh they like the
idea of uh one if they have investors
that they can reach out to and get help
for and things like that uh two also is
if you've got a big audience like you do
uh there's advantages right when they
make the announcement of the fundraise
you've got a name that people recognize
you've got a platform that you can
promote them if uh it's that type of
business or whatever what's your
relationship like with the founders
because you get a lot of [ __ ] going on
right you got a whole team what is that
like uh when you make investments in
some of these companies yeah so
um my my partner Jeff and I we each each
company is different but um
it just really depends what they need
um and sometimes we take a passive role
and so and most of the time we know
whether or not we want to be passive or
not so sometimes we're just money and
you know maybe they call and like need a
connection or an intro like sure no
problem uh but then some companies we
could like actively really help
um and so
those ones it could be you know we get
advisory a lot of times we get advisory
on top of our investment and we could
help them with their marketing or
um just advice or taking like a
consultancy position
um helping them with their branding a
lot of times I get on and like tell
these people like all right this you
could be doing this better on social
media you could be you know this Tick
Tock needs to be changed you need a
different editor you need a better logo
you know your slogan sucks like whatever
it might be
um
but we we do get active in certain
companies where we know we could provide
a lot of value and sometimes I do
commercials for them sometimes I'll post
on my on my Twitter or my Instagram
um
you know backing them
um so it really just depends
um I want to ask about three companies
specifically one uh you guys bought
shares in Endeavor I think right there
was the UFC yeah
whose idea why'd you do it and did
anything actually come out of you guys
advocating for them changing stuff
um
we did it to
um
to be able to be a part of their monthly
or I guess it's quarterly uh update
calls just didn't like know what's going
on with their shareholders like how much
they're paying UFC fighters
um we were on a call and like someone
did bring up they didn't let us talk but
that someone shocking yeah crazy that
someone did bring up
to them like what about like Jake Paul
and pain Fighters more and you need to
be paying Fighters more and so there is
an actual like what's their response uh
that he he just like brushed the
question off and was like we're not
doing that right now like just
brushed it off like a professional yeah
but
um duck duck to the question
um
but
I I think the idea is like we're trying
to find all of these ways to actually
create change
um and attacking it from all angles
um and and that's that's really where
the idea stemmed from uh Andrew is a
company that uh is kind of very Cutting
Edge Innovative when it comes to uh
defense Technologies uh I know that you
all invested there what was the thought
process like why are you excited about
that space yeah I just thought it's
super cool super futuristic
um the the the
founder lucky Palmer like has a ton of
track record a history of success I met
him at a party once and he was like a
super cool guy we shared interests and
and hobbies
um and do I want to ask what hobbies and
interests he collects cars okay and so
like
um I don't have like a big enough garage
space yet to collect cars but like I'm
slow I have kind of a car collection
like I have like 10 10 cars and and
slowly slowly growing if I can make more
space
um but but when I'm older I'm gonna have
like a hundred [ __ ] cars
um but what's your favorite one
oh so that's uh it's so tough to say are
they like classic cars like I like all
yeah classic cars like I love the
Thunderbird
um I want to get that one day that it's
my grandpa had it and so I was just like
always loved it growing up
um but also like super cars too like I
want the Porsche
um the Porsche 918 spider uh that's like
my my goal what do you drive on a
day-to-day basis
um I mostly Drive uh a Lincoln Navigator
because
it's like more low profile a lot of
times if you're like driving around like
a [ __ ] Lambo or some crazy [ __ ] like
you're just drawing unwanted attention
to yourself and at a certain point of
Fame you
you know you just do the opposite of
draw attention to yourself you're like
[ __ ] this I don't want to be seen by
anyone I don't want a hundred people to
ask me for pictures like tinted windows
car that blends in with everyone and I'm
gonna go about my daily business and
hopefully no one bothers me what about
the golf cart is it a stock golf cart a
highest ride it's uh it's technically
not stock I got Aftermarket seats I got
a pin a racing stripe down the side
um and it's the fastest one the fastest
available one it goes like 35 it's quick
it's quick but it's a it's a Polaris gem
um
great great vehicle in Puerto Rico yes
I'm whipping that [ __ ] non-stop all
right uh is it weird being famous like
when people are coming up to you do you
enjoy it or are you now like hey that
was cool when I was younger but like
it's getting old now how do you think
about the fame it all depends it's
definitely weird like I forget sometimes
when I'm in training camp for a while
and I'm just like I don't see a lot of
people yeah and so like you forget
you're famous I forget I'll literally go
out in public and be like oh [ __ ] like
like because I'm I'm so you know alone
and by myself in training camp and then
I it just like it's like a culture I
don't know it's like a shock to the body
um going out in public like that and I I
it depends man I really enjoy it when
the kid it's a kid most of the time like
when the kids get excited and you could
tell they're actually a fan and you know
that to me is super cool
um it's it's the people who are like
disrespectful or like they're not
actually your fan they just want to take
a picture to be like uh yeah I saw him
or whatever and they could be they could
be super rude man I I have like probably
one rude encounter with someone anytime
I'm in public like once a day if I'm in
a public area like for on a repeated
basis
people just like don't treat you they
think you're a zoo animal and they're
like come here like take a picture with
me and like they don't even say please
or just like demanding it some people
have like had dozens and dozens of
people walk up
boom take a picture without saying
anything I'm I'm like just standing
there and I'm like and they just walk
away looking at their phone like
like a zombie [ __ ] real like it's a
[ __ ] I don't know the NPC or some
[ __ ]
and I'll just even look at you just
looks in the phone takes the picture and
then just walks away looking at it like
I don't know but
um
but man I like it's it's really awesome
when I can make someone's day
um and
do you get people who are like I don't
know if you go to bars or you're out at
night or whatever you go to a club an
event whatever and because they you're
like oh you think you're a boxer like
I'll [ __ ] you up and people start
talking [ __ ] if they're drunk
um it doesn't happen as often as you
think the the number one thing that
happens is
uh dude
walking like if we're walking in a
public place and it's like a crowded
area let's say like a mall the number
one thing that happens is there's always
the war dude who's clearly walking the
opposite direction that's like you're a
[ __ ]
and like there's it's usually like in a
group so you can't you don't really know
like which one said it yeah
um you should do what Nate Diaz does he
just like you know kind of like flexes
at everyone yeah and he's [ __ ] like
he saw the one where the guy is like
drinking up in the air yeah right yeah I
just I don't care I think it's funny
like when they're like you're a [ __ ]
like I think most guys like I don't need
to prove myself like I'm like all right
bro like that that moment for him in
front of his friends like made his day
him cooler to his friends because he
said you're a [ __ ] to Jake Paul and me
like I just I don't I don't care uh and
I'm not like a hostile person like I I
leave it all in the the ring so what's
the craziest situation you found
yourself in from a Fame perspective
whether it's you met somebody like I'm
meeting you whether it was like oh [ __ ]
let's get the hell out of here like I'm
in danger like what's the craziest thing
I think a moment that stands out was uh
this past New Year's
we're on this boat in Saint Barts and
like there was just an absurd amount of
celebrities on it like Leonardo DiCaprio
Mike Tyson Drake Meek Mill little baby
uh the the list goes on I can't I I
forgot I don't know there's just a who's
who of the world yeah and it was like
this like casual sort of party it wasn't
like a rager and so everyone was kind of
just talking and like there was no ego
and we're on this probably
one uh probably one billion dollar yacht
and uh it was just kind of surreal I was
like why the [ __ ] people and people knew
who you were
yeah no I was yeah and I was trying I
was chatting with all of them had like a
really good combo with uh with Drake and
then uh talked to Mike Tyson for a
little bit and what's he thinking about
you fighting he loves it he loves he
loves me and I love him he's such an
awesome guy so much wisdom
um and he just gives me tons of advice
and and just support always and publicly
too he's he's backed mean
um and and talked about my skill and you
know to me that that means the the most
is like when the legends of the sport
are like this kid's legit what he's
doing for the sport is great
um it's easy to like get lost in the in
the comments and and in the Sheep hating
on you
um but the guys like Roy Jones Jr
Holyfield Tyson uh all of the Legends
have showed love even Tyson Fury
um and current active Champions and
Anthony Joshua I was just with him and
he was you know singing singing praises
and uh that to me means more and uh is
there anybody who's a legend in boxing
who is like this is horrible for the
sport like [ __ ] this guy
they are aware of at least
I don't think so I don't think so I
haven't seen it and I don't pay super
super close attention but like I don't
think there's someone who like you hang
your hat on you're like that person
hates the fact that Jake Paul's bringing
attention to boxing yeah no I don't I
haven't really seen that
um
which which I guess is like kind of the
The Telltale sign
um you know
if if the your peers respect you then
yeah that's the most important as part
of Fame you're still like a relatively
young guy uh you're married what's going
on are girls like hit you up and like
damning you and [ __ ] well where Julie
and I aren't aren't married but we look
we look like we're married though damn
near um you should just say you're
married yeah
Julia if you're watching this
um are you gonna get married gonna get
married yeah yeah does she know that or
did she just find that out listening to
this no no no she she knows that okay
she she like
has been telling me uh
for the past three years
is she gonna propose to you I that's
what I told her I was like if you want
if you want to get this done
just get it you better be careful you're
gonna like your next fight you're gonna
be done with the fight knock some dude
out you're gonna turn around the knee
that's hilarious that's hilarious
um but are girls like hitting you up and
stuff and and uh like just doing all the
[ __ ] that people would expect if you're
famous and you're on the Internet or
what's going on but yeah for sure I mean
I I don't I don't look at it though yeah
like I I think it's more like in public
they like try to come up and talk to me
but then Julia just like looks them in
the [ __ ] eyes and they they go away
I've met her and it strikes me that
she's not playing around yeah she
doesn't play around at all she she's
almost fought like three girls before
really yeah she definitely hit one girl
before
could she win in a match she's strong as
[ __ ] yeah yeah she's really strong she's
Filipino and so I always joke that like
our kid is gonna be the next Manny
Pacquiao
so and she's strong like
and has long arms so it's it's really
it's looking good for for my kid in the
boxing career
I'm just wondering if we're gonna see
like a card where it's Logan versus
someone you verse someone and then Julia
steps in the ring she they've like
offered her to step in I don't think she
wants to actually box yeah but but
they've offered her money yeah yeah she
said no yeah all right
um when we think about kind of moving
forward uh better you've spent a lot of
time on is a a business I think you
invested in uh the initial business uh
simple bet yeah right and then you guys
also launch better which like a consumer
betting app why are you spending so much
time money energy and uh frankly just
like attention on something in the
betting space yeah so
um
basically
I want to change Sports and not just
boxing but just Sports in general and
there's so many that's such a big task
right but I think
and I I love I've always loved Sports
I've always loved watching sports
talking about sports my friends and I
think there's a there's a gap in the
market where there's so much room to
innovate on like what would ESPN look
like if it was launched today
um and
that's that that's in and of itself is
like a super intricate conversation but
I think that
sports betting uh and the sports Media
company that we're creating together can
just make Sports more fun and make
Sports better
[Laughter]
um but uh
also
I've always wanted to like put all my
eggs in Steam behind a company since I
was 18 years old I was like what is my
you know proper 12 what is my taramana
tequila uh you know what is the 50 cents
of Vitamin Water
um Yes siroc Prime uh Happy dad for the
milk boys Mr Beast is doing the food
what what is mine
um and uh
the star is just aligned in in so many
perfect ways and I I'm a huge believer
that like the sports betting industry is
like just at its start
um it hasn't really been made fun for
kids my age
um to like 21 to 30 year olds and that's
the audience we're trying to make sports
betting like a social thing because me
and my friends we never really talked
about sports betting and
it's for a multitude of reasons some
states that you're in it's not legal
right but that's being ahead of the
market right so that's also a good thing
is is getting in before 50 states have
sports betting legal and that
opportunity growth is is massive
um and there's you know 10
or probably five multi-billion dollar
companies
um who in my opinion
aren't doing that good of a job of
getting users and um brand Affinity uh
the apps are clunky and hard to use and
when I first used the better demo and
met Joey the CEO I was jumping out of my
chair having fun sports betting for the
first time
um and making it simple like no one
knows about like the minus 850 plus 3
000 money line this uh over on like all
of that stuff is just makes the barrier
to entry like way too hard
um and I also
just saw
so much room to to grow there because I
saw these Brands who weren't doing a
good job and they were also paying me
millions of dollars just like throwing
millions of dollars at my face
for what I didn't think was like good
promo they didn't really know how to
activate my audience they didn't but
listen to me and my creative input when
they were throwing me all of this money
and so I
just saw how they were misspending money
um and
saw the opportunity uh in the market to
enter in and just do everything
completely different in a in a uh in a
vertical that I love which is sports and
I think that's where like the passion
has to be there if you're really gonna
like Change the World
um with a company
um
and yeah I guess that like in short is
sort of why uh I'm I'm going all in on
on better you mentioned changing Sports
uh once you conquer boxing would you go
try to play in the NFL NBA golf like go
play some other sport or what's the plan
yeah yeah I I think uh I I could see
myself for sure in like three or four
years
um going and trying to get on an NFL
team on NFL team yeah what position
um
slot receiver most likely because I'm
I'm decently fast fast enough to be a
slot receiver I can catch
and my height and weight like fits that
position the best
um and I would want to score a touchdown
I I wouldn't want to be on defense and
just like not be able to get a touchdown
so would the haters be louder for boxing
are you on an NFL team
probably me on an NFL team
I think I think again people would be
like oh you can't play football you're
not people don't think I'm an athlete
like
genuinely
um
so they wouldn't believe or or think
that I was actually gonna go and do that
yeah uh and then on the business side
like what do you want your legacy to be
do you want to be a billionaire do you
want to uh build a billion dollar
company like what are like goals or the
things that you wake up and you're like
man it'd be cool to accomplish this I
think yeah the the challenge of creating
a billion dollar company is like real
life
the hardest
actual game in the world like it's like
real life Monopoly how do you
how do you play that game and and be
successful at it
um and I've always just wanted to do it
because
I've always said if that guy can do it
then why can't I and I think it's fun to
like figure that out and it's the
ultimate Challenge I believe
um and that's what wake that's what gets
me excited every day is is just having a
challenge in front of me
um to chip away at slowly
um
but yeah I mean I I don't know I think
that there's so much
there's so much uh that I want to do I
think we're my legacy
when I think about my legacy I think
about changing this Combat Sports mostly
um and leaving it in a 10 times better
place uh than where it started and
helping Fighters and getting Fighters
paid more getting them long-term Health
Care
um advancing Sports Science within the
sport because of of the dangers that
surround it and making sure Fighters you
know continue to
uh continue to have proper Health after
they're done fighting because right now
they're you're just on your own it's
like oh you're done fighting like you
get kicked to the curb
um and I want to open up
more and more boxing gyms we've opened
up three already
um and working on a couple more as we
speak that are being built just for kids
to be able to go to for free
um and that's through my Foundation
boxing bullies and helping people
um get into the sport and fall in love
with it because of
how it changed my life I believe it
could change so many other people's
lives and then just helping people like
Amanda Serrano who
who you know choose underpaid you know
is one of the best fighters of all time
but never really got the recognition
um and just bring in a spotlight to to
Fighters like her and uh making her
dreams come true has been super
fulfilling for me
um
but
ah
yeah that that seems to be the Legacy
and I think I would love to like have a
family
um
that to me is really exciting
have to be boxers the kids yeah
YouTubers then boxers are just straight
to the Box straight to boxing I'll be
their promoter
they'll sell hella pay-per-views just
because of their name so you'll be like
a Lavar ball yeah literally that's
exactly what I'll be you ever seen the
clip where he walks onto the ESPN set
and he's got a I think it's lamelo uh
maybe and they're walking they're just
like man that's not dead like yes
can't do anything about it he's walking
out there like he's the NBA player yes
yes main character energy that that is
the thing though is I would let my kids
uh play basketball basketball basketball
or boxing
football is just like so much injury
yeah and you know you don't even you
can't even see their face so it's just
not good for Branding you and Logan
fight who wins me
he agrees I think so yeah I've seen him
I've seen him talk about it on podcasts
and I think he he always says like right
now he would beat me but I think if we I
if we actually were to fight then I
would train and then I would come back
and win how many pay-per-views do you do
if you two get in the ring together
is that is that the biggest fight it I
think it is probably bigger than you and
uh Andrew Tate
I think it is
I mean no one's ever done it before no
no one's ever like the brothers that
both box have never fought each other
the clinch goes never did it
Charlie Brothers haven't done it and
there's a bunch of others but
um
is that what you two are [ __ ]
scheming up well not really we like talk
about it yeah and our parents are like
absolutely not like they get pissed when
we even talk about it
um
but also
like
yeah we gotta get the fans what they
want but I'm also not the one who would
lose so it's he would be the one that
would have to live with that result
so if he can do are you a psychological
warfare already
yeah
yeah
it starts now sorry Logan you know Dana
White's master plan is to get the Logan
Brothers uh or the Paul Brothers
together in the UFC who knows
that's crazy
I mean it's the biggest is the biggest
UFC pay-per-view they've ever had yeah
no doubt about that maybe maybe that's
Dana's plan I don't know who knows what
that that guy's doing I smell a
retirement soon from him you think he's
gonna retire yeah why
I think he's just like kind of over it
like I don't know
and the UFC is just not it's not what it
was why not it's I think it kind of
already peaked you think the UFC has
peaked yeah okay why they just don't
have like any uh they no they they have
some stars like two
whereas before and like the heydays
there was like [ __ ] 30 Stars 20 stars
that could all sell pay-per-views and
now there's different organizations that
are competing that have a lot of uh hope
and promise and funding and good
Fighters
um so it's not just like this one place
anymore
um and
there's just also boxing is made a major
comeback so for like 10 years no one was
really
raving about boxing
um and now there's this new generation
of talent so there's other Combat Sports
so no one's just sitting around watching
the UFC anymore there's
tons of exciting boxing fights all the
time sometimes on the same night as UFC
events
um
so yeah I think they've they peaked with
with McGregor like that was their
McGregor versus khabib like that was the
peak they'll never they'll never get
anything like that again you think
McGregor's done
I don't [ __ ] know I I think he has to
come back and fight but he needs to win
he needs to win will he fight you I
don't I don't think he will I don't
think he will why
I think my skill level like
is outgrowing his inboxing and I have
the
the height Advantage
um we would weigh the same but like
he he can't beat me and I think he
probably knows that in like time he's
only getting older and I'm only getting
better so
who knows and I don't think the risk for
him is worth the reward yeah even if he
gets paid 100 million dollars it's just
not worth it yeah I think he's like it's
not about the money for him really I
don't think anymore yeah yeah let's just
leave it there I appreciate you coming
in honestly I hope people realize that
uh uh one you're much better at boxing
than most people realize but also you're
not a complete [ __ ] as probably many
people think of a stupid YouTuber yeah
uh so they do yeah keep it up
[ __ ] them off into the bank